the Laker front line when he penetrates
slingshot knocks it down
Lynn puts it up Mike I like this Lynn
picks it up Lynn drives in and late
development he'll get there quicker
knocks it down and on the floor Lynn
likes the Open Floor spinning puts it up
and backs it in
Lynn gets inside flips it up and in
four-point game under three and a half
Lynn on the drive Banks it in out to
Lynn Lynn fakes pull-up jump shot knocks
it down
crowd wants him puts up the two-pointer
punch it in Jeremy Lin with 30 31. how
about frees another rebound
Lynn for three
Lynn on the drive gets inside Banks it
in as the undrafted point guard from
Harvard electrifies MSG once again
[Applause]